notre invité aux politiques ce matin
c'est jacqueline gourault bonjour
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nos
ministes de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales en étant 100 pendant 20
minutes est à mes côtés pour cette
interview romain gaspard de la gazette
des communes bonjour normand on va
évidemment parler longuement de la loi
cadre des ans que vous présenté ce matin
en conseil des ministres et en gros mais
d'abord l'actualité et l'actualité c'est
ce qui s'est passé hier à l'assemblée
nationale hier soir et cette nuit
l'assemblée nationale qui a donc
finalement adopté le passé ni terre
après avoir voté contre une première
fois et la république en marche a été
lâché par le modem qui a voté contre se
passa ni terre comme les oppositions est
ce qu'aujourd'hui le modem est encore un
allié de la majorité présidentielle
jacques brot willy à oka dr yann marti
n'y a aucun doute c'est une discussion
parlementaire comme il y en a eu
beaucoup d'autres où chacun exprime ses
convictions et ses positions et ça s'est
arrangé comme vous le savez dans le
dialogue puisque ça a été voté à une
heure du matin
alors ça s'est arrangé mais il a eu
quand même des mots assez forts de la
part de députés du modem il n'y a pas eu
de dialogue d'écouté sur les nez rouges
du texte au sein de la majorité est ce
que vous sentez encore élucidées mais
aujourd'hui je crois le pardon est ce
que vous vous sentez encore considéré
comme membre du modem en juillet contre
la majorité par les mains il allume à
considérer peut y avoir ici ou là des
maladresses des uns et des autres et
vous savez même à l'intérieur de la
majorité ou même à l'intérieur dans
marche
il y a parfois aussi des discussions à
l'intérieur même du parti
ne faisons pas je peux pas dire d'une
montagne quelque chose qui n'est qu' un
incident parlementaire qui s'est
finalement arrangé mais pour vous c'est
pas au delà de l'incident parlementaire
on a l'impression que cela vient après
d'autres épisodes ya notamment eu
l'épisode de la proportionnelle on sait
qu'au modem vous tenez beaucoup à la
proportionnelle emmanuel macron la
refuser cette proportionnelle est-ce que
ça na pas les indépendantistes emmanuel
macron la refuser pendant mes dix ans et
la fin du quinquennat verra dans le
temps oui
mais vous savez qu effectivement le
modem est très attaché et ça depuis
longtemps à la proportionnelle est-ce
que ça a laissé des traces quand même
nom canal va laisser des traces
nous défendons des positions auxquelles
nous croyons dans une majorité
ça n'est pas être bénis oui-oui et dire
tout et dire oui à tout il y a des
discussions ont construit des majorités
on discute
et puis après les décisions sont prises
et voilà et on continue et on continue à
faire des listes dans un scrutin
régional qui arrive bientôt où nous
sommes clairement à lier ensemble la
majorité en faisant des listes en marche
modem agir et toutes les composantes de
la majorité ce que le modem est allé
selon les régions un an
non le modem n'est pas à lié selon les
régions le modem
non mais c'est pas ça s'il ya peut-être
des individualités qui n'ont pas
respecté les consignes du modem ça ça
arrive notamment si on souffre beaucoup
d'armes sont avec la dérive
régulièrement
à toutes les élections régionales mais
il n'y a pas de décision différente du
modem selon les régions donc vous nous
dit aujourd'hui que ce qui s'est passé
hier c'est pas un moyen pour le modem de
montrer que la république en marche n'a
pas la majorité sans vous il faut pas y
voir un signe comme ça aussi le modem
est une famille politique le modem à un
héritage politique le modem défend ses
convictions dans la majorité et c'est
bien normal et il y a encore une fois à
l'intérieur dans marche aussi des gens
qui ont des convictions qui défendent
leurs convictions chacun des bas il y à
des votes effectivement eu un premier
vote qui
a été repris si je puis dire par une
deuxième délibération et qui affecte
tout le monde s'est mise avait fait
céder le gouvernement sur plusieurs
points les oreilles à l'écouté du modèle
ont fait céder leur domicile vous enfin
bon vous voulez si vous voulez me
comment dire me dire qu'il y a
où poser sa en conflit ça n'est pas un
conflit c'est un une démarche normale de
la vie démocratique et de la vie
parlementaire
l'autre sujet d'actualité c'est cet
hommage national qui a été rendu hier au
policier éric masson et jean castex qui
annoncent un renforcement des peines
pour les agresseurs de policiers et de
gendarmes
les élus aussi sont victimes
d'agressions de plus en plus fréquente
de plus en plus violente
est-ce que vous souhaiter un
renforcement des peines pour les
agresseurs d'élus oui et c'est
d'ailleurs prévue dans un projet de loi
que nous a présenté le garde des sceaux
par ailleurs je vous rappelle que le
garde des sceaux a déjà fait une lettre
à l'ensemble
du corps de la magistrature pour
expliquer combien les attaques contre
les élus étaient gravissimes et qu'il
fallait une réponse pénale qui soit
adapté je vous rappelle d'ailleurs que
nous avons dans la loi de décembre 2019
la loi engagement et proximité voté
aussi la protection juridique et
fonctionnelle des maires pour évidemment
les conséquences qu'ils peuvent avoir
des agressions et que l'état prend en
charge cette protection pour les
communes de moins de 3500 habitants
c'est à dire la majorité des communes en
france alors il faut agir aussi sur
l'accompagnement le ministre de
l'intérieur a prévu aussi un
accompagnement des forces de police du
gign par exemple pour aider les mères à
régler des situations conflictuelles
il y a je crois plusieurs leviers sur
lequel il faut agir et en tout cas
politique pénale également mais qu'est
ce qui est prévu en plus pour les élus
jeudi politique pénale c'est-à-dire
renforcement des bébés allemands
renforcement des peines contre à la fois
les agressions des policiers et des élus
par exemple pour les policiers
concrètement en ce qui concerne les
peines concernant les refus d'obtempérer
vont être ça a été annoncé largement les
policiers on a bien compris mais pour
les élus qu est-ce qui aura en plus de
ce qui est déjà inscrit dans la loi
engagement et bien des annonces vont
être faites et il y à un nouveau de la
sécurité qui en ce moment permet de
réfléchir à la fois sur la protection
des policiers mais aussi des élus qui
représentent la république et donc leur
à de nouvelles annonces pour les élus à
quelle échéance je n'ai pas d'échéance
précise
connue mais la protection des élus est
un élément fondamental de la volonté du
président de la république du ministre
de l'intérieur et du ministre de la
justice roma on va parler d'un sujet qui
inquiète les élus en ce moment oui c'est
le la suppression du corps préfectoral
annonce par jean castex
il ya eu beaucoup d'insistance pendant
la crise par le gouvernement du coup
maires préfets qu'est-ce que ça va
changer cette suppression du corps
préfectoral
est ce qu'il ya un risque pour les élus
de faire face à adé préfet moins
expérimentés
alors il n'y a pas dessus alors il faut
être clair parce que quand vous dites
suppression du corps préfectoral je ne
peux pas dire que vous disiez pas la
vérité mais ça peut être compris comme
suppression des préfets et de l'exercice
de la mission et de la fonction de
préfet je le dis haut et fort
les préfets sont maintenus évidemment
dans leurs missions leurs fonctions et
au contraire on veut on faire un corps
fonctionnel si je puis dire oui c'est ça
hein quand fonctionner et donc
la volonté du président de la république
et du premier ministre c'est de
moderniser le corps de préfet de
l'ouvrir à des formations différents des
parcours différents mais le préfet qui
et je dirai sur les territoires le
représentant de l'état restera le
représentant de l'état
et je dirai au contraire et y compris
dans la loi 4d que nous allons tout à
l'heure précise et le renforcement du
rôle du préfet est à l'ordre du jour
très justement va parler de cette
macabre où le texte arrive assez tard
dans le quinquennat est ce que vous avez
la garantie de pouvoir la mener au bout
de la navette parlementaire sachant que
les parlementaires ont ont dit qu'ils
allaient fortement l'enrichir et ont la
volonté de proposer beaucoup
d'amendements écouté le débat
parlementaire aura lieu ici au sénat le
5 juillet donc on à la session de
juillet qui nous permettra de faire la
première lecture le gouvernement va
déclarer l'urgence sur ce texte bien
évidemment pour qu' il y ait une seule
lecture et éventuellement évidemment une
cmp puisque je ne pense pas que c'est un
vote conforme il faut pas rêver si je
puis dire
et pour l'instant la date n'est pas
encore finalisé mais il est possible que
la lecture à l'assemblée nationale se
fasse dès la rentrée et pourquoi pas
éventuellement dans une session
extraordinaire
donc ça veut dire dès septembre voilà
c'est sûr mais quand je dis cela encore
une fois ça n'est pas arrêté mais c'est
une possibilité qui a été étudiée nous
évidemment tout le monde
tout le monde a envie que ce texte
évidemment et le gouvernement en premier
se finalise rapidement et je me réjouis
d'ailleurs de constater que c'est aussi
la position du sénat j'ai bien sûr
regardé à la conférence de presse du
président du sénat en compagnie des
rapporteurs dont mathieu darnaud qui
sort de ce studio et qui ont clairement
annoncé leur volonté positive de voir
aboutir ce texte il ya quelques semaines
vous annoncer dans la gazette des
communes que c'était pas une la loi
cadets pas une grande loi de
décentralisation pourtant dans le cadre
d il ya décentralisation est-ce que
c'est pas un peu contradictoire et
concrètement c'est quoi l'objectif de ce
texte
alors vous savez je crois que dans la
vie politique et a fortiori quand on est
ministre il faut dire toujours
clairement les choses et depuis le début
de la préparation de ce texte
j'ai toujours annoncé que ce serait une
forme de décentralisation un peu
nouvelle avec normalement une marque de
différenciation très importante de
déconcentration et même de cycle de
simplification donc depuis le début je
le dis parce que réduire ce texte au
fait de transferts de l'état vers les
collectivités ça serait inexact prenons
un exemple concret si vous le voulez
bien
par exemple il va y avoir des transferts
effectivement qui vont se faire on va
finaliser par exemple on propose de
finaliser le transfert des routes au
département et au métropole puisque
c'est dans un souci aussi d'efficacité
mais on le propose pour les départements
volontaires ces voiliers l'idée c'est à
la fois de la décentralisation mais qui
n'est pas imposé et qui se fait en
fonction des territoires sur les routes
il ya une fois sur les les sondages
qu'on fait les associations d'élus il ya
peu de collectivités qui sont favorables
astres
ce faire comment vous l'expliquez alors
c'est pas une déception
moi je fais pas des sondages je discute
avec les départements
il y a à peu près la moitié des
départements qui sont intéressés par le
transfert des routes
alors bien évidemment qui dit transfert
10 transferts de moyens
je le dis tout de suite parce qu'on dit
toujours mais comment il faut qu'ils
aient aussi temps c'est inscrit dans la
constitution que tout transfert comme ça
a été le cas dans les décentralisations
précédente
sa compagne de transfert de moyens
et puis la différenciation elle peut se
concrétiser de manière différente aussi
elle peut se faire par l'expérimentation
par exemple vous savez que les
départements qui sont particulièrement
concernés par cette loi
cadets
les départements en tout cas certains
départements sont en attente d'une
modification du fonctionnement du rsa et
je prends l'exemple de la seine saint
denis qui est très comment dire actives
sur le sujet eh bien on va faire une
expérimentation pour se re
centralisation entre guillemets du rsa
puisque la partie comment dire la partie
accompagnement et insertion restera au
niveau départemental donc là on fait de
la différenciation je dirais par
l'expérimentation
deuxième exemple on fera en droit d'en
comme on dit dans lure
on fera aussi de la différenciation par
exemple il ya dans ce texte aussi des
choses qui comprend qui concerne pardon
les territoires font très frontaliers et
nous avons besoin de mesures pour
répondre nous en avons beaucoup parlé
dimanche à strasbourg avec le président
de la république et les élus on a besoin
d'outils juridiques pour pouvoir mener
des politiques transfrontalières par
exemple construire un hôpital
transfrontalier une école
transfrontalière etc
on revient sur ce que vous dites parce
que c'est quand même important sur la
question des moyens on vous dit c'est
inscrit dans la constitution que tout
transfert de compétences de sa compagne
et de moyens vous avez bien sûr entendu
les critiques les inquiétudes surtout
des élus inquiétudes relayées aussi par
le cndd puisque mathieu darnaud nous
disait que ça allait être l'une des
priorités du sénat de omettre la
question du financement au coeur de ce
texte est ce qu'il ne manque pas
clairement un volet financement dans ce
non mais c'est pas à voler ça n'est pas
un texte de financement et si vous
reprenez des lois de décentralisation ce
ne sont pas des textes de financement le
financement et comprendre et bien sûr
question financement comment vous allez
c'est comme tout ça se discute
c'est simple il ya des dépenses qui sont
faites les années qui précèdent les
transferts on regarde combien il y a eu
fonctionnement combien il y a eu
d'investissement et ses dénégations des
négociations qui se font avec les
associations d'élus et avec ce qui est
notamment les présidents de départements
qui demanderont un transfert je le dire
il n'y a pas de miracle il n'y a pas de
femmes segura bras dans la loi qu'on
soit maintenant mais puisque c'est
inscrit dans la constitution
alors évidemment ça fait toujours je
comprends et mathieu darnaud est à sa
place en 10 ans on sera très attentifs
aux moyens transférés aux collectivités
territoriales très bien j'ai été
sénateur je sais de quoi il est question
mais évidemment que c'est un sujet qui
est important évidemment que tout cela
sera discuté cancan l'association des
maires de france en particulier françois
baroin indique le texte est à des années
lumière de ce qu'il faudrait les
départements hier dans une tribune dans
le monde parle de textes en relief est
ce que c'est une déception
un coup dur pour pour vous de voir ce
tir de barrage des associations d'élus
qu'on ne tacle en tout cas d'une partie
importante des associations d'élus
écoutez je suis habituée aux prises de
position des associations d'élus moi
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
j'ai fait un texte en concertation avec
les élus
alors certes avec les concertations avec
les collectivités territoriales
mais sur le terrain il ya bien sûr eu
les négociations avec les associations
mais j'ai fait plein de réunions dans
l'ensemble du territoire soit en
physique soient en vision puisque la
crise de l'aco vide est arrivé que j'ai
voulu dire que je vais vous dire ce que
j'ai lu absolue et 2000 élus je sais ce
que j'ai entendu je connais les as tu
les attentes des élus et je réponds par
ce texte a beaucoup de demandes des élus
d'ailleurs j'étais assez intéressant
parce que en même temps il ya les
critiques qu'on ne va pas assez loin
enfin etc
mais en même temps il ya le travail que
je continue à faire toutes les semaines
avec les associations d'élus pour
préciser un certain nombre jusqu'au
dernier moment de choses qui sont dans
le texte donc ya alon disons les
postures et puis il ya le train
irréel qui se fait derrière et je peux
vous assurer que tous niveaux de
collectivités territoriales est concerné
mais en particulier les départements et
je dois dire que dans le protocole que
nous avons signé avec l'adf est et en
charente-maritime chez son prêt leur
président dominique bussereau il y avait
dans le texte du protocole d'accord il y
avait des comment dire l'accord d'une
comment dire sur le principe d'un texte
4d qui était cité alors bien sûr
est ce que ce ne sont que des postures
parce que le sénat aussi vous avez suivi
à la conférence de presse vous ne l'avez
noël sénat aussi la consulter les élus
qui sont des élus territoriaux on a aimé
tout lyon de remonter les toulousains
droit nous aussi donner plus de
décentralisation plus de proximité une
simplification des normes comment vous
allez répondre à ça mais on y compte par
des tas de mesures dans le texte par
exemple puisque vous parlez les
simplification des normes
c'est une autre manière de faire de la
décentralisation nous allons des centres
et déconcentrés pardon
ou décentralisée décentraliser le
pouvoir normatif aux collectivités
territoriales sur leurs compétences
une liste très précise ça n'a jamais été
fait c'est ce gouvernement qui va le
faire au lieu que ce soit un décret qui
encadre je ne sais pas le nombre
[Musique]
deux personnes dans un cis on va
transférer la capacité selon
l'importance de la commune et cetera
sur le nom par délibération de la
collectivité c'est la première fois que
ça se fait donc on est d'accord sur les
grands principes décentralisation
deuxième principe très fort respect des
territoires
troisième principe le pouvoir normatif
plus adapté au terrain quatrième
principe une déconcentration des de
l'organisation de l'état sur les
territoires on est d'accord sur les
principes d'ailleurs je dois vous dire
que sur les 50 propositions du sénat le
texte
on comprend à peu près on en a repris à
peu près la moitié
nous en avons parlé j'en ai parlé moi
même avec le président du sénat et il y
en a encore certaines qui peuvent parer
mandement être apportées donc je je veux
dire par là moi je suis confiante parce
que je sais ce que je fais tous les
jours avec les élus locaux
je sais comment je travaille aussi avec
les associations d'élus
alors après on est dans une période
particulière ça ne vous a pas échappé
qu'il y avait des élections régionales
des élections de la folie départementale
mais fait de la politique il sait pas
une faute de faire de la politique mais
vous me permettrez de dire que je
travaille régulièrement avec l'ensemble
des élus et l'ensemble des associations
d'élus et je sais que nous avançons
ensemble pour un texte qui apportera
beaucoup de réponses et
d'assouplissement sur les territoires
quelques questions pour finir on sort un
peu de la loi cadre des mais c'est quand
même des questions qui inquiètent les
élus les collectivités là le coût de la
campagne de vaccination qui a un coût
notamment pour les communes
est-ce que ce coût sera compensé
intégralement pour les communes et quand
alors
d'abord il est déjà prévu que les cours
avancés par les communes font l'objet
dans les budgets d'une ligne
particulière et qui permettra d'amortir
supplée plusieurs années les dépenses
engagées par les collectivités
territoriales
ça c'est déjà fait deuxièmement
il va y avoir avec les directeurs
d'agencés régionales de santé des
conventions qui sont signés par les
villes qui ont des centres de
vaccination et le ministère de la santé
lui même va compenser le surcoût des
dépenses qui est fait pour les centres
de vaccination mais concrètement avant
le voir quand dans leur budget les
communes ce remboursement
c'est des conventions qui seront signées
actuellement et ça va être remboursée et
comme on a remboursé les masques parce
que peut-être on oublie ça mais on a
remboursé aussi des masques aux communes
et ça a été un chèque très important
parce que joël giraud qui était sur ce
plateau il ya quelques semaines et nous
disait ça sera dans le plf de l'année
prochaine pour vous ça sera avant
écoutez le ministère de la santé signent
des conventions lui même avec les
municipalités et un mot sur une dernière
question sur un autre sujet la question
de la taxe foncière la taxe foncière la
mf dans dans une étude dit qu'il ya un
tiers des communes qui se prépare à
augmenter leur taxe foncière ou qu'ils
ont augmenté pour faire face aux pertes
de recettes de la crise tarifaire est-ce
que c'est au contribuable de payer le
manque de compensation du gouvernement
est ce que vous comprenez que ces élus
augmentent leur taxe foncière
alors ce n'est pas une étude c'est un
sondage faut dire les choses c'est une
enquête avec la brique intérêts devant
voilà c'est une voie là deuxièmement si
vous reprenez et vous le savez très bien
puisque vous êtes un spécialiste
les premières années qui suivent le
renouvellement des équipes municipales
il y a toujours augmentation des taxes
j'ai regardé la précédente période c'est
25% des communes qui ont augmenté les
taxes foncières troisièmement vous dit
quelque chose de faux la compensation de
la taxe d'habitation est totale moi je
pensais sur les relais le coût de la
crise sanitaire parce que c'est souvent
ça qui en avant par les élus
parce qu il ya aussi la taxe
d'habitation qui est mise en avant est
les compenser intégralement
donc on ne peut pas me disent que c'est
des pertes de recettes center alors sur
la crise sanitaire je rappelle tout de
même qu'un filet de sécurité a été votée
et appliquée en 2020 et que ce filet de
sécurité compenser les pertes fiscales
et les pertes domaniale des communes et
donc ces communes si elles avaient moins
de ressources en 2020 de la moyenne des
trois années précédentes elles étaient
compensées reste déjà justement encore
je travaille avec olivier du soft sur un
dossier qui pour certaines communes qui
cumule un certain nombre d'inconvénients
si je puis dire les problèmes des régies
voyez quand certaines communes c'est
très inégale selon les territoires
c'est très inégale quand certaines
communes on sont une station de ski en
plus ont une station thermale et que
tout ça est fait en régie ils ont des
pertes qui sont considérables outre nous
sommes en train de réfléchir pour voir
si nous pouvons sur ces communes très
touché trouver un moyen de les aider
je voudrais terminer en disant que
contrairement à ce qui a été craint et
je le partage est finalement la
situation des collectivités
territoriales est beaucoup moins
comment dire grave qu'on ne l'imaginait
puisque la moyenne
c'est une augmentation
des dépenses de fonctionnement de + 0 2
et une baisse des recettes de mois 1,4
donc et grâce d'ailleurs au filet de
sécurité
et je rappelle que ce filet de sécurité
va s'appliquer en ce qui concerne les
ressources fiscales également en 2021 et
merci beaucoup merci merci un rose
[Musique]